[Music]
hi everyone my name is Wojtek and i
wanted to share with you a short story
about my experience with the new cullen
multi-platform projects in Kotlin one
three so when we come to these
conferences talk about Android talk
about running Kotlin on Android for
making Android that's what we really
mean is : JVM
that's the Kotlin that we know that gets
compiled to Java
and then you know we can transform it
into Dex files run it on Android but it
can also run on Cloud Servers on our
desktops and so on now there are two
more flavors of Kotlin actually or
compilation targets first one called nsj
for running javascript in a web browser
environment or even something like cloud
functions or nodejs and then there's :
native which compiles down to machine
code in you know native libraries that
can run or target various platforms such
as iOS desktop apps even web assembly
and even Android so how do we actually
get started with this so count them 1 3
introduces a new project structure and a
new plug-in that's called called a
multi-platform and if you apply that to
any of your modules you can then select
from a preset from a set of presets to
target any of these platforms so here
for example I'm targeting a Android
library and ajs target now when you add
these to your module it automatically
creates source sets for each of these
platform specific cutland files so if
you put your column files in the J's
main folder they will get compiled or
transpiled to JavaScript files now what
do I mean by calling specific sorry
platform specific Kotlin now if you go
and browse the documentation the
reference pages for each of the column
packages and you mouse over any of them
in the top right you will see these
multicolored chips that tell you which
compilation target this library is
available on so here for example the
Kotlin browser package that lets you
access interfaces for document and
window from the web browser environment
probably only makes sense on a gest
target and that's that's how it is now
fortunately many many of the core
libraries and functions are available
across
all the compilation targets in fact you
can see a fourth one cutland common
which means this is a pure Kotlin
library that can run independent of any
platform that's targeting and in fact if
you add a multi-platform plug-in to your
project along with the platform specific
source set you also get a common source
set where you can put platform
independent code now the thing about
platform independent code is it cannot
call any of the platform api's it cannot
call any of the J's specific or Android
specific ap is the other way of course
works you can have your platform
specific code from any of the flavors
depend on a shared common library or
source set so knowing all that I set out
to write an example app just to learn
about called a multi platform and I
decided to make a small Sudoku game now
one thing I have to say about Kotlin
multi platform is it's not a toolkit
that lets you write an app once and run
it everywhere I still need to create an
Android app with Android specific code
just like I normally would and then a
web page with some JavaScript code just
like initialize things like entry points
to my app lifecycle UI and so on but
then what I do is all my shared business
logic so in my case it's the pseudocode
engine that solves and generates two
Doku boards for me I take it out and put
it in a shared library using caudill in
common and in fact the only source set I
have in this library is common main so I
put all my code there and that means
it's available across all the platforms
that I choose to target ok but then I
thought ok I have this core engine for
solving my Sudoku code but I would also
like to draw the board on the screen and
why code it for each platform separately
if it should look the same on each of
them so I thought wouldn't it be nice if
I had an API for drawing on the screen
that's completely platform independent
something I can multi platform canvas
but then what I want to do is I want to
actually have it delegate to each of the
platform simple implementations so I
want to use the Android canvas to draw
an Android while I use the HTML canvas
to draw on a website the thing is I just
told you that Kotlin common code cannot
call any platform interfaces so I
currently depend on these and export
them from from this
module so how does it does it work in
Kotlin well there's this this expect an
actual mechanism lets you declare
expected classes in your common code
which is something like almost like
defining an interface in Java and then
in each of my platform specific source
set I provide the actual implementation
that can depend and use platform API
such as the Android canvas now when I
add that dependency from my common
source set to the other one and looks
something like this but actually when
compiling for a specific platform such
as Jas this depends on dependency will
actually use the correct html5 canvas
[Laughter]
okay if I could just show the link to
the project so that everyone can look at
it that would be great
[Laughter]
[Music]